[Musique]
non
pour dîner ça va te mange
[Musique]
senna confirme la braconne
abracadabra entrer dans la danse
la magie commence sans la caverne
abracadabra pour moi c'est moi j'ai un
petit casse croûte à chambon un peu oui
j'irai relation chiche à la limmat
oui mais elle est tombée elle est tombée
regard hagard pour toi pour toi alors là
maintenant hop tu vas une chose 6 2 sur
et oui encore une 3 4 6 et finalement
pour te faire plaisir
une cinquième schiste
voilà et
car oui jedessine chiche mais ces patchs
elle a heureusement que je suis là un
chagall voilà du sel
[Musique]
m
il est sain tu vois
et oui oh là qu'est ce que tu sais et ça
dans la main ou lotus et il faut se
méfier des évidences parce que regarde
c'est maintenant j'ouvre la main plus
rien à
n'a plus de salle bayard évident toi
aussi à la machine moi j'ai trouvé une
soeur dire mais vides at anciens
professeurs comme ça qu'est ce que tu
veux que je fasse une satire vita
[Musique]
prochain
bon
ah ah
et oui elle s'est remplie j'étais bien
d'attraper un média maintenant oui j'ai
dû cendre oui mais j'ai pas de soucis ce
assez vrai effet coûte peut-être pour
toi
[Musique]
à voir la ti des égards c'est un vrai
chapelet là tu es tranquille tu en as
pour des jours et des yeux mais qu'est
ce que tu attends attends j'ai trouvé
une fourchette pour adapter mais
saucisses attends attends je vais la
crap et c'est son rôle là ou là et c'est
pas bien vivante
[Musique]
et
e
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
wade
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
pauline est antagoniste au couteau
[Musique]
jours
oui
[Musique]
c'est un message qui vient de chine
jean baucou monsieur le facteur chinois
maintient 10 dont pascal tu dis que
toujours collection de timbres tu veux
bah écoute alors d'accord un écoute on
ne sait jamais avant d'ouvrir cette
lettre je vais te donner
voilà on va découper le timbre et je
vais te le donner d'accord homme écoute
j'ai fait une bêtise et la lettre et oui
j'ai découpé le message est découpé la
lettre tout on va leur écoute là
vraiment je suis très embêté regard des
deux partis maintenant qu'est-ce que je
vais faire écouter à moins que à moins
que c'est peut-être un message chinois
magique c'est travail qu'est ce qu'il ya
d'écrit dessus alberto attends attends
attends rien inquiet non coupable non
coupable oui pas dire ici connaît encore
un don chinois va les amis a bien
entendu un truc pour faire cela et je
vais vous l'indiqué il faut avoir une
enveloppe truqué mais qui est très
facile à truquer regarder ce qui se
passe derrière cette enveloppe qui est
normal vous avez simplement des coupes
et deux fentes avec vos ciseaux de
fentes l'une près de l'autre et alors là
il faut savoir que mon passé le message
ou la bande de papier derrière voilà
vous rentrez par le bout qui a été
découpée aussi bien entendu et en face
comme cela et le truc
et oui ce qui fait que de ce côté tout
paraît normal mais de l'autre côté
et bien pour l'instant vous pouvez
d'ailleurs caché avec les doigts si vous
voulez montrer des deux côtés alors voit
rien on est alors maintenant au lieu de
découpe et de ce côté je vais vous
montrer ce qui se passe derrière c'est
très simple on place l'un des bouts du
site des ciseaux sous la banderille on
découvre enveloppe de cette façon voilà
ça lors de notre côté il faut bien
cachés pour qu'on ne voit pas comme
saisi le message qui n'est pas coupé
laisser comme cela et alors à ce moment
là quel dommage
un petit geste magique et bien sûr le
message est toujours entier alors ça
peut être une bande de papier avec
n'importe quoi à 20 jours qui viennent
acheter un château et c'est le premier
jour il va visiter banni des cheminées
comme tous les fantômes
tiens mais peut-être et oui il est
encore là et à la fin qu'est-ce qu'on
retrouve le fantôme attaque mais avec
une bande de papier on peut en faire des
choses
regarde si on prend une demande de
papier et maintenant on l'appelait en
deux on la coupe par ici un garde bien
ce qui se passe et pourtant maintenant
que ces coupes et un petit geste est là
bas revient comme au départ mais à
l'abandon ce que vous ne savez pas c'est
que si je coupe encore une fois et cette
fois au lieu de couper droit si je coupe
de travers comme ceci alors là qu'est ce
qui va se passer bien c'est là
qu'intervient la magie et regardez bien
cette fois et puis on obtient le papier
qu'ils aient un mystérieusement
raccommoder de travers rosset alors ses
atours tordu
[Musique]
à
on
[Musique]
oh
à
aum
oh
[Musique]
on
e
m
oh
[Musique]
à
en
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
200 ch est un beau champion
de quoi réaliser un équilibre
très facile
avec une bouteille
[Musique]
comment verser
toute l'équipe de la bouteille sans que
le bouchon tombe du dessus
[Musique]
voilà maintenant vous serez le faire
vous aussi
[Musique]
quand j'y pense
bon
lee
et
[Musique]
oui car dit-on
ok
com
hook
week
[Musique]
bien
et
hi hi
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
j'étais à l'approché toi
[Musique]